foreign
hey welcome back to Lori Farm everybody
uh today we're going to be doing a
hydraulic fluid change on this old 1949
8N tractor so to start there's a there's
actually three main drain areas on the
tractor that you're going to want to
drain from directly below the
gear shift but on my tractor I don't
know what the previous owner did I have
no idea this thing almost looks like it
was either mangled up or welded on or
something I'm not going to be taking
that off today I'm a little bit worried
that once I get it off I'm going to have
a problem so we're going to start on
this bolt over here it's right next to
the exhaust and uh I think I've watched
a few videos and guys have said that
theirs is a 9 16. mine's a three-quarter
I don't know if
if it was changed out at one time which
is why it's a three-quarter but that's
where we're going to start
um the tractor should hold five gallons
of hydraulic fluid when
um when it's full so I have a
three gallon bucket here so we're gonna
have to stop at some point
I've actually never taken this bolt out
I've done changes on it before but I
always took the
the big one here in the back loose
exclusively but I thought today I'd try
this one all right well we let that
drain out of there a little bit this uh
this rear one I think is an inch and an
inch and a sixteenth which
on hand that socket so I'm going with a
an inch and an eighth that I have
put a rag in just to get this thing
loosened up
like I said there should be five gallons
in here so I got a little three gallon
bucket so we might stop a little ways
and
and uh
go pour out into a bigger bucket and
come back and get the rest
well while that's draining down on the
bottom of the tractor whatever
open the cap here up on the top for the
fill
it uh it looks like it's a
looks like it's a bolt but it's actually
not
kind of like a radiator cap almost
I'm actually surprised the old oil
doesn't look too bad
so that's a good sign I remember the
first time I changed it that uh
it was pretty white and scummy
well there's probably a million great
ways to fill but that's the way I'm
Gonna Fill things up the the dipstick is
over here underneath the underneath the
seat
and um
so we'll fill for a little bit and then
we'll we'll check our level and see how
we're we're doing
and we'll check our fluids here
pretty hard to see on there but it
should be right on the money well we got
the oil all put back and got the cover
back on so ready to go we'll fire her up
and see if she holds
well thanks for hanging out today and uh
hopefully we all learned something and
maybe you guys want to check out this
video right here have a great rest of
your day